il agace il dérange sans doute parce
qu'il fait de la politique loin des
codes habituelles avec lui la politique
est forcément un sport de combat avec
pour ring TikTok plutôt que l'hémicycle
[Musique]
bonjour Louis voyages alors votre
arrivée à l'assemblée a fait baisser la
moyenne d'âge de des députés dans
l'assemblée mais pas seulement vous avez
aussi eu un autre effet vous avez donné
un sacré coup de jeune à la
communication politique on va le voir
madame la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur face au fil d'étudiants devant
les distributions alimentaires pourquoi
l'action du gouvernement est-elle aussi
pauvre qu'un sandwich du CROUS
cela leur apprend la valeur du travail
je pense que l'État fait déjà beaucoup
les Bourses ont augmenté de 4 % en
raison de l'inflation comment est-ce
qu'on peut dire féliciter nous on a fait
4 % d'augmentation des bourses alors que
vous avez seulement 38% des étudiants
qui touchent la porte donc une immense
particulière de la touche pas et que
l'inflation est après 6% du coup vous
n'avez rien revalorisé du tout puisque
les étudiants ont perdu de l'argent
alors ce qu'on vient de voir là ce sont
deux extraits de vidéos que vous avez
postées sur Tik Tok qui ont fait
respectivement plus de 4 et 5 millions
de vues je crois je suis pas sûr qu'il y
a un député qui est fait autant de vues
comme ça avec des prises de parole dans
l'assemblée ou en commission c'est une
fierté pour vous ça là on était le plus
étonné c'était en commission enfin non
en fait notre objectif c'est du de
s'approprier des codes qui sont ceux des
réseaux sociaux et qui sont aussi les
nôtres enfin moi-même j'utilise ces
applications je regarde du contenu
dessus mon équipe aussi et donc du coup
en fait on utilise nos codes pour
pouvoir intéresser les jeunes à la
politique le but c'est de parler aux
jeunes bien sûr le but le but c'est de
parler aux jeunes de leur montrer ce qui
se passe à l'Assemblée nationale de leur
donner un argumentaire de leur donner
des chiffres et puis aussi de leur
montrer nous notre position et en fait
on va là on la génération 2000 est entré
à l'Assemblée avec ses propres codes
culturels ce propre code politique aussi
on les utilise et puis bon bah ça
fonctionne alors ça vous vaut quand même
d'être qualifié de députés tiktokeur par
vos adversaires dans leur bouche c'est
pas forcément un compliment quand vous
le prenez vous je m'en fiche c'est pas
eux que je veux parler je vais vous
assumer ce côté député tiktoker en fait
je j'assume d'être un député qui essaie
de parler aux jeunes et pour parler aux
jeunes je vais pas le faire de manière
descendante en leur demandant de de
s'institutionnaliser eux-mêmes au
contraire je veux que l'institution
s'adapte aux jeunes qu'elle s'imprègnent
des codes culturels de la jeunesse pour
justement les attirer vers la politique
parce qu'on dit beaucoup la jeunesse
elle est pas politique elle s'en fiche
de la politique c'est pas vrai je crois
que la jeunesse n'a jamais été aussi
politisée parce qu'elle est ultra
connectée elle est ultra informée à tout
le problème c'est que il y a un décalage
entre les jeunes et l'institution et du
coup ce que j'ai essayé de faire c'est
de les reconnecter mais en montrant des
interventions de l'Assemblée nationale
avec nos codes et ben je les reconnecte
sauf que parfois vos codes à vous
peuvent choquer l'institution qui est
l'assemblée par exemple sur la réforme
des retraites vous avez lancé sur
Twitter un concours des meilleurs photos
de blocus de lycée ou de campus avec à
la clé une visite de l'Assemblée à vos
côtés ça vous a valu une réplique assez
sèche de la présidente de l'Assemblée la
politique n'est pas un challenge TikTok
vos adversaires vous ont reproché
d'abaisser la politique c'est elle qui
abaisse la politique tous les jours il y
a LeBron Pivet j'ai beaucoup de
critiques à faire sur elle la manière
qu'elle a d'utiliser sa fonction de
député et en vérité je lui demande pas
non plus son avis mais vous avez vous
avez le sentiment que ça tire vers le
haut de faire ce genre de choses je
crois je crois sincèrement oui parce que
au fond qu'est-ce qu'ils ont reproché
dans cette vidéo c'est pas le fait que
j'utilise Tik Tok il s'en fiche de ça
c'est pas le fait que je fasse un
challenge TikTok il s'en fiche de ça
c'est le fait que je reconnaisse aux
jeunes la légitimité de bloquer leur
lycée leurs universités et c'est mon
opinion politique je reconnais aux
jeunes la légitimité politique de
bloquer leur lycée leurs universités
c'est ça qui les a scandalisés et
justement nous on ramène des sujets
vis-à-vis de la jeunesse vis-à-vis par
leur légitimité de bloqué sur les
questions de réchauffement climatique
sur les questions de précarité et ce
sont des choses qui n'ont pas envie
d'entendre parce que ce sont des sujets
sur lesquels ils sont mauvais et parce
que on leur met dans les yeux la misère
dans laquelle ils enferme les jeunes
alors il s'indignent et ils préfèrent
regarder le doigt plutôt que la lune
alors là vous parlez politique et d'un
coup vous animez et vous prenez un ton
différent et ça m'intéresse parce que il
y a votre façon aussi de faire de la
politique qui est différente elle des
tonnes dans le paysage de l'Assemblée à
peine élu député vous êtes fait
remarquer c'était lors de la toute
première séance de l'Assemblée vous
étiez là en tant qu'accesseur et vous
avez refusé de serrer la main de
plusieurs députés du rassemblement
nationale c'était quelque chose de
préparé pas une avance c'est quelque
chose dont je me suis retrouvé à cette
position je me suis dit mais j'ai pas
envie de leur serrer la main parce que
je n'ai pas envie de serrer la main
médiatique non c'était pas un coup
médiatique bah écoutez vous arrivez vous
savez je pensais pas que ça allait
monter comme ça mais ça a permis de
mettre en avant un sujet politique qui
est celui de l'institutionnalisation du
rassemblement national et du fait que ce
qui était anormal il y a 20 ans et
devenu normal aujourd'hui et donc moi je
voulais pas leur serrer la main parce
que c'est comme ça moi je sers pas la
main aux gens du RN quand j'en croise
parce que je pense que ces gens ont des
idées politiques qui sont nausées à
bondes et qui sont même sont
incompatibles avec la République donc
j'ai pas voulu le faire parce que c'est
la personne que je suis et derrière ça a
fait du bruit et donc du coup on a
utilisé le bruit que ça a fait pour
porter un sujet politique qui est celui
de l'institutionnalisation du RN dans
nos dans l'Assemblée nationale vous
donnez souvent l'impression de vivre
votre engagement comme un combat presque
physique comme un corps à corps avec
l'ennemi mais on va on va prendre des
exemples par exemple vous avez été
blessé au pied par un tir de flash-ball
pendant une manif des gilets jaunes vous
avez rendu fou Cyril Hanouna sur son
plateau télé il vous a traité de tocard
de merde et de bouffons et il y a des
militants d'extrême droite qui sont
venus vous menacer sur le campus de la
fac de Bordeaux où vous êtes rendu avec
votre collègue Carlos Martin bilongo on
a l'impression qu'avec vous la politique
c'est ça se transforme forcément un peu
en combat de boxe que il faut forcément
une dose d'agressivité voire de violence
moi je lâche vous pouvez regarder dans
tous les sujets dont vous parlez c'est
pas moi qui suis violent c'est des gens
qui essayent d'être violent avec moi
c'est vous vous déclenchez une forme
d'agressivité vous avez pas le sentiment
d'être agressif bah non je crois pas et
d'un autre côté je suis aussi lucide en
disant que dans la politique il y a une
forme de violence la politique ce n'est
pas que des beaux discours sous les
dorures de la République c'est des
conséquences dans la vie des gens et
pour beaucoup la vie est violente pour
beaucoup la misère est violente pour
beaucoup la politique de Macron et les
mots du rassemblement national sont
violents vous avez un mot d'ordre qui
est de tenir tête oui c'est ça aussi qui
se traduit à travers votre
oui bien sûr parce que enfin en fait oui
il faut leur retenir tête parce qu'on
reconnaît souvent pas la légitimité à la
jeunesse de tenir tête à la classe
politique à la classe médiatique et a
beaucoup d'autres on leur reconnaît pas
cette légitimité et oui c'est un combat
politique il faut l'assumer comme tel et
c'est sain d'ailleurs de l'assumer de la
contrepartie de tout cela c'est que
l'adresse de votre domicile a été
dévoilé sur les réseaux sociaux sur
Internet vous avez été suivi jusque chez
vous vous avez reçu des menaces de mort
à votre domicile tout ça vous a valu
d'être placé sous protection policière
surveillance sous surveillance policière
mais vous dites quoi c'est le prix à
payer de votre engagement
c'est-à-dire que si jamais il y a des
gens qui qui en sont réduits à tout cela
pour nous intimider c'est bien qu'on
leur fait peur c'est bien qu'on les
embête donc du coup écoutez j'ai envie
de dire tant mieux
on va remonter un peu dans le temps pour
voir que cette façon que vous avez de
mener vos combats elle était là dévot
tout début c'était en fin 2017 vous
étiez lycéen on a détecté de l'amiante
dans votre établissement c'était à
Villeneuve-le-Roi et vous avez alors
pris la tête de la mobilisation des
élèves
on est fatigué de tout ça et puis
surtout on faut penser à notre bac on a
des élèves qui sont en décrochage
scolaire qui ont vraiment arrêté les
cours on en a d'autres qui vont échouer
sur leur bac on est les premières
victimes de tout ça alors ça c'est une
de vos toutes premières prises de parole
vous voyez rire parce que
ça me fait c'est drôle voilà comme ça à
l'époque c'est drôle de revoir vous avez
l'air vraiment très à l'aise pour cette
prise de parole comme si vous aviez fait
ça toute votre vie ça tient à quoi c'est
que à ce moment-là j'essayais
d'expliquer que laisser des élèves
respirer de l'amiante c'était dangereux
et je m'acharnais à essayer de répéter
des évidences jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit
entendue et mais comment vous en êtes
venus à apprendre la parole au nom de
vos camarades de lycée bah c'est parce
que
il y a eu donc l'histoire avec l'amiante
avec les collègues de du lycée on s'est
dit bon bah on va on va monter un
syndicat on va se battre et puis bon bah
naturellement c'est comme ça c'est moi
qui ai commencé à prendre la parole j'ai
des prédispositions quoi pour pas
écouter apparemment ça a fonctionné
alors par la suite vous êtes devenu
président de l'UNL l'Union Nationale
Lycéenne vous êtes battus contre
parcoursup contre la réforme du bac est
globalement on peut dire contre la
politique d'Emmanuel Macron comment vous
êtes politisés aussi jeune quand j'ai
terminé la lutte dans mon lycée donc on
a bloqué pendant trois mois avec le
soutien des professeurs qui ont effectué
un droit de retrait on a obtenu la
reconstruction du lycée et après l'un
des membres du syndicat dans lequel
j'étais venu me voir il m'a dit bon bah
ils sont en train de faire parcoursup à
ton avis vu le lycée pourri d'où tu
viens tu penses que tu as plus ou moins
de chance qu'un autre bon j'étais en
train de comprendre que j'étais de ceux
qui allait se faire avoir donc je me
suis battu contre parcoursup et puis
après il y a eu la réforme du lycée la
réforme du baccalauréat et à chaque fois
que je m'engageais politiquement dans
une cause je découvrais qu'il y en avait
1000 autres alors vous avez été dans une
grande précarité pendant la durée de vos
études vous avez fait la manche
ponctuellement vous avez bénéficié de
l'aide alimentaire pour les étudiants
vous en parlez souvent d'ailleurs de ce
sujet dans dans l'hémicycle et vous avez
même dit de la drogue à un moment pour
vous aider à vos études et sur ce
dernier point c'est un sujet dont vous
voulez plus parler pourquoi alors même
en plus en général en fait je c'est
assez difficile de pouvoir parler de
précarité étudiante en parlant de sa
précarité étudiante parce qu'à chaque
fois j'ai l'impression qu'on qu'on rend
la chose pathétique je n'ai rien de
pathétique en même temps ça vous donne
peut-être une forme de légitimité en B
oui mais justement cette légitimité là
elle vient pas du fait je vais enfin il
y a rien de pathétique dans la précarité
étudiante tous les étudiants sont dans
la précarité et c'est pas faire la
manche qui allait demander de 0 pour un
sandwich tout le monde fait ça et sur la
question de la drogue c'est quelque
chose dont j'ai pas forcément envie de
parler parce qu'encore une fois on va
plus parler de ce sujet là le
caricaturer que du véritable sujet qui
sont les étudiants qui vivent dans la
précarité c'est ça en fait et quand
j'essaye de parler de moi ou même quand
on se retrouve à avoir un effet
médiatique qui fait qu'on parle de moi
mon seul objectif c'est de parler de
politique ensuite de parler tout le
monde et je fais justement attention sur
les sujets dans lesquels je mets en
avant parce que je ne veux pas être le
centre du sujet le centre du sujet c'est
l'intérêt général aujourd'hui vous
gagnez 5841 euros net par mois je crois
en tant que député vous avez dit
récemment je ne suis pas à l'aise je ne
vois pas en quoi une telle somme est
justifiée c'est indécent il faudrait
faire quoi selon vous pour que vous
méritiez cette somme d'argent en tant
que député c'est pas une question de
mérite c'est pas une question de rapport
à soi c'est une question de rapport aux
autres je colle vers tous les jours je
fréquente des personnes qui vivent avec
400 euros par mois il y a un autre chose
qui m'a qui me marque beaucoup c'est le
bureau de poste que nous avons à
l'Assemblée nationale avec des
fonctionnaires en nombre dévoués
compétents ouvert très souvent et le
bureau de poste de ma ville
Villeneuve-Saint-Georges qui est
quasiment pas ouvert et en fait je vois
un tel décalage entre le service public
et le revenu qui est proposé aux
Français et notre service public à nos
députés et celui que notre revenu à nous
c'est un décalage qui me met mal à
l'aise quel regard est-ce que vous
portez sur sur votre mandat de député
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est à la
hauteur de ce que vous espériez ce qu'il
y a des déceptions est-ce qu'il y a des
frustrations je
m'attendais à ce que la nouvelle
composition de l'Assemblée nationale
nous permet juste de faire avancer des
sujets qui soient consensuels faites qui
n'est pas de majorité qu'on puisse
réussir à faire passer des lois
finalement non tout le monde est plus
sectaire les uns que les autres et c'est
difficile de pouvoir véritablement faire
avancer l'intérêt général avec nos
propositions mais par contre on a des
débats de fonds on a une Assemblée
nationale qui est regardée et ça permet
de mener la bataille culturelle et je me
sens très à l'aise dans cette Assemblée
nationale parce que bon bah je sais que
beaucoup ne m'aiment pas et d'un autre
côté je ne cherche pas à être aimé par
eux je cherche à mener une bataille
culturelle et beaucoup de français nous
regardent et c'est ce que je trouve bien
on passe à notre quiz à présent si vous
voulez bien je vous explique le principe
je vais commencer une phrase et c'est
donc vous connaissez la compléter devoir
porter une veste dans l'hémicycle c'est
c'est pas obligé de le mettre dans le
règlement quoi mais vous le faites vous
l'avez aujourd'hui je n'ai pas le choix
parce qu'ils ont fait mon dehors ils ont
fait un règlement de l'Assemblée
parce qu'ensuite à tout moment vous
devez rentrer dans l'hémicycle je l'ai
constamment histoire d'être constamment
prêt à pouvoir les voter une bonne prise
de parole dans l'assemblée doit
forcément
être comprise
si je dis ça c'est parce que quand on
parle à l'Assemblée on parle pas
uniquement pour les députés on parle
pour les personnes qui nous regardent et
j'ai même envie de dire on parle plus
donc l'objectif c'est d'être
intelligible pour le public auquel on
veut parler c'est d'ailleurs le sens de
tout ce qu'on fait sur les réseaux
sociaux juste pour conclure vous avez
vous avez été lu à 22 ans vous voyez
faire de la politique jusqu'à plus de 70
ans comme Jean-Luc Mélenchon ou tout
autre chose c'est une grande question
que je me pose avocat vous vous rêviez
moi je rêve mais je rêve toujours d'être
avocat j'aimerais être avocat pénaliste
et je pense faire ça dans ma vie voilà
j'aimerais merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]